welcome back to New rockstars I'm Eric
Voss and black panther what kind of
forever has released new footage
revealing deeper insights into the
film's antagonist Namor or Namor played
by tinoshuerta the ruler of the
vibranium enriched undersea Kingdom of
talocon Marvel actually released two
scenes one of Neymar confronting shuri
and raimonda another of Neymar and his
Warriors attacking wakanda and there are
some interesting things that come up in
both of these and I thought I'd break
them down for you now I was fortunate to
see this movie early at a press
screening I posted my initial spoiler
free reaction in a Twitter thread and I
will not be spoiling any of the movie
secrets in this video I will be focusing
solely on promotional material released
by the studio what we see in these two
scenes in another trailers and nothing
else and thanks to kiwico for sponsoring
today's video more about them later
let's start with this clip of Neymar
meeting shuri and raimondo released by
Marvel Studios as a promo clip into
nocha where it's his appearance on Jimmy
Kimmel this place is amazing
the air is pristine on the water my
mother told stories about a place like
this a protected land with people that
never had to leave but never have to
change who they were what reason did you
have to reveal your secret to the world
I am not a woman who enjoys repeating
herself
who are you I had many names my people
call me
but my enemies so the seed confirms that
wakanda has some water access that
connects all the way to the ocean I
broke down the geography of where
wakanda is located in the comics and in
the MCU in another video but the closest
real world coordinates of wakanda in the
film Universe based on a map shown in
Civil War has it bordering Uganda Kenya
South Sudan and Ethiopia bordering Lake
turkana while the Black Panther film art
book depicts the country in the east
African Rift Valley bordering Rwanda the
Democratic Republic of Congo and Uganda
now there actually is a water route all
the way to Central Africa from the
Mediterranean Sea from the Nile River
all the way down to Lake Victoria that
is a long swim both across the continent
and in elevation since Lake Victoria's
3724 feet that's 1134 meters above sea
level so the fact that Neymar has swam
all this way and found a way to breach
wakanda's perimeter is enough of a
symbolic threat to these leaders of
wakanda he marvelous that this country's
natural beauty Untouched by the outside
world and complements both the air and
the water which is a key distinction
between Neymar and the other people
talocon trailer footage shows that on
land all of them must wear water-filled
breathing apparatuses whereas Neymar as
mutant is not confined quite like they
are now Neymar says his people call him
kukul Khan which as I've explained in
trailer breakdowns is the Mesoamerican
serpent deity worshiped by the ancient
Maya people but he says that his enemies
call him Namor and yes to no chuerta
does use a different pronunciation there
but keep in mind he does say this is a
name his enemies have given him I mean
that's important anything I can tell you
that his pronunciation is no accident we
can all still call him name or I'm sure
it's fine but I like how this connects
with the way that the MCU is often
touched on the idea that their superhero
monikers are given to these Heroes by
others with hostile intentions like the
way the name of She-Hulk was assigned to
Jennifer Walters by the media until she
later embraced it now during the virtual
press junket the always on point
moderator Jacqueline Coley straight up
told to no swear to that he was a quote
steal your girlfriend kind of guy and I
couldn't have described his character
better myself the way name or completely
takes over this movie he is so much fun
to watch in it there are lots of ways to
become a superhero you can be born with
superpowers get them through a freak
accident or you can be really good at
making gadgets and If You're Gonna Save
the World you might as well learn how to
make things first well kiwico can help
with that Kimiko is a subscription that
provides you and the kids in your life
with a new Hands-On project every month
they teach you about things like science
and engineering while being really fun
at the same time everything you need
comes in the great saving multiple trips
to the store or a bunch of research on
blogs DIY sites it's a great way for
parents to make their home or backyard
entertaining on a budget all of kiwico's
projects are designed by experts and
tested by Kids 1 000 hours go into
developing every single crate that means
you'll get that whoa moment when you get
to see the connections happening this
month we got the Domino machine which is
adorable and functional it comes with
everything you need to build it articles
about the physics The Dominoes batteries
the whole nine yards and here's one that
we built in the office check it out
holy crap that was awesome kibiko makes
such a great gift for any young person
in your life most kiwico subscriptions
are under 20 a month and they also have
one-off crates in their store if you
want to try it out and support new
rockstars click the link in the
description and get your first month
free but let's move on to the second
clip released by Marvel showing the
Warriors of tallul Khan attacking
wakanda by flooding it trailers have
shown water surging through the streets
of wakanda and this clip shows just a
bit more
foreign
[Music]
first responder from walking off a ledge
in the water and they throw a grenade
into a group of Tallow Canyons that are
in the water and if you listen closely
right before that explosion you can hear
a choir of singing voices and those
voices scream and cease right after the
Boom
foreign
so from this we are able to determine
that one of the telecon attacks is
singing a kind of enchanting siren song
that hypnotizes people into walking into
the water this could be another example
of the MCU intersecting with Greek
mythology the sirens in Greek mythology
the sirens are humanoid creatures who
appear in Homer's Odyssey and other
Greek myths singing to Sailors from far
away and luring them into their Islands
but then dooming those Sailors by
sending them crash into the rocks of the
shore the implication actually could be
that the tall Canadians are in the MCU
the actual source of the Sirens of Greek
myth now solicon is established as being
in the Atlantic Ocean a lot of Greek
myths are based in the Mediterranean Sea
but it seems like the twilikrian's turf
encompasses all in seas and if Neymar
did indeed take a Mediterranean route to
get to wakanda it's totally possible
that storytellers all over the world
over the centuries could have been
inspired by solo Khan another detail and
this makes sense but I just love that we
get to see what kind of First Responders
in action as a peaceful Advanced Nation
you might think that wakanda might not
really need civil rescue workers but you
know accidents can befall any Kingdom
and it just shows how the wakanda's
priorities are in check like by
comparison I don't think we ever saw the
firefighters of Asgard or the paramedics
of xandar just another example how the
Black Panther movies are really really
good at World building and fleshing out
their societal structures a telekinesian
climbs up a trolley and by the way
teleconian if you're rolling your eyes
at it this is the term that Kevin feige
said on the red carpet that's what he's
calling him so it's what I'm gonna call
them anyway this Warrior climbs up onto
this trolley and pulls the driver into
the water remember we saw these Street
trolleys in the 2018 film and sure he
Pilots an Airship with Anika and fires a
tow cable to lift the trolley to safety
you know what do you think about it in
phase four shung Chi stopped the bus Dr
Strange dismantled the bus Cersei turned
a bus into flower petals and now shuri
is towing a bus Marvel phase 4 certainly
loves to pair are their Heroes with
public transportation meanwhile another
telegon Warrior threatens a different
voter and mbaku comes to the rescue
creeping it behind him tripping them
clubbing him and flying him off to Hell
Followed by a well-earned victory chest
though now we know from here based on
other trailer shots that mbaku will leap
over to attack Neymar from behind and
Neymar will block the attack and break
mbaku's club and then we've also seen
plenty shots of Neymar he's in his
flight agility to take on the wakanan
air fleet you can specifically see how
his ankle Wings allow him to zigzag and
pivot mid-air with a close-up of his
foot turning in front of the camera I
cannot wait to watch this movie again
and to hear all of your thoughts about
it because this will probably be one of
the final if not the final pre-release
black panther what kind of forever
videos you see on this channel next week
Jessica Clemens will be hosting our
spoiler free review a couple days before
the release so you know what to expect
going into the movie Mt will break down
the post-credits scene right after the
release and I will be doing our deep
dive Easter egg breakdown on release
weekend within the days and weeks beyond
that further breakdowns explainers and
theories coming from all the wonderful
hosts I'm lucky to get to work with here
at new rockstars you can follow me on
Tick Tock Instagram and Twitter
Rockstar subscribe to new rockstars for
more analysis of everything you love
thanks for watching bye
[Music]